[Musique]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau c'est eu d'écho nous allons
faire un focus sur l'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion de la semaine dédiée à ce
thème qui se déroule du 23 février au 3
mars
c'est parti
vous
job dating conférences forums tous les
acteurs de l'emploi et de la formation
de san quentin en yvelines se mobilisent
sommaire et à l'occasion de la semaine
de l'emploi nous ferons un point sur
l'événement avec erwan le gac conseiller
communautaire délégué de saint quentin
en yvelines en charge de l'emploi et de
l'insertion professionnelle
focus sur le cabinet ftc digital item la
mission du cabinet basé à maurepas et de
présenter les meilleurs candidats aux
entreprises il utilise une méthode de
pointe l'étude comportementale et puis
nous avons suivi sabrina ou dit la jeune
femme de 25 ans est à la recherche d'un
poste depuis deux ans elle mise tout sur
l'événement tout pousse pour un emploi
qui s'est déroulée le 23 février à
maurepas
quelques chiffres sur l'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines
il y à 142 mille emplois dont 92 % de
salariés 8 % de non salariés 46 5% de
femmes et 52 5% dom
la répartition des postes salariés par
taille d'établissement démontre que les
emplois sont principalement dans les
grandes entreprises
72 % dans les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés 18% entre les pme
et 10% dans les tpe
[Musique]
on peut parler de monde du travail sans
faire un point sur les agences pour
l'emploi il y a cinq agences dans la
région les résultats de pôle emploi sur
leur territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est près de 11000 retour à
l'emploi à la fin en 2016 sept
demandeurs d'emploi sur dix sont
satisfaits du suivi dont ils bénéficient
des taux de satisfaction des entreprises
qui vont de 10 72 5% pour autres apps à
75,20 que 8 % pour but en cours cette
semaine de l'emploi a débuté à maurepas
avec l'événement coup de pouce pour un
emploi organisé à l'espace albert camus
cet événement permet à des jeunes de
bénéficier d'entretiens directs avec des
recruteurs allons à leur rencontre
[Musique]
on prend les premières expériences en
tout cas même vous n'avez pas
d'expérience on vous forme et on place
chez nos clients
ici sur mort passé la première fois du
coup qu'on participe à ce forum
mais on espère pouvoir le faire
dans la durée c'est très important on
trouve quelques quelques pépites
effectivement après il faut que les gens
soient bien motivés c'est quelque chose
sur lequel on est très ouverts nous
actuellement on participe à beaucoup de
forums des forums écoles et des forums
également voilà avec la région on a une
politique nourrie qui est d'insertion et
de recrutement local et donc c'est un
des
meilleur événement pour ce type de
besoin que l'on peut exprimer
nous avons pu voir que les entreprises
jouent véritablement le jeu du
recrutement lors de ce type d'événement
mais que représente réellement le marché
du travail
aujourd'hui focus sur l'entreprise fdc
digital technologies un cabinet de
recrutement spécialisée dans le digital
le cabinet ftc digital items existe
depuis 2010 ils sont spécialisés sur les
métiers du digital et de l'haïti leur
but trouver des bons candidats pour
intégrer des entreprises installées à
maurepas
ce n'est pas par hasard qu'ils ont
choisi le département des yvelines
si on prend le département des yvelines
pour faire un petit focus
il y à l'heure actuellement 650 me
d'actifs d'accord et 60 mille demandeurs
d'emploi qui correspond à peu près peu
ou prou à la moyenne nationale de 10 %
de taux de chômage sur blocs économiques
aussi en partie de l'innovation
effectivement les besoins de demain
seront les besoins sont des métiers
d'innovation ont des métiers dans le
high tech
il faut savoir que être ici jeetah et
aiment qu'on leur présente
nous sommes spécialisés sur ce créneau
sur les métiers du digital de l'actif
le cabinet travaille avec des grandes
entreprises comme la saur le groupe
ducasse ou encore vivendi si elles font
confiance à ftc digital item c'est parce
que le cabinet met toutes les chances de
son côté pour présenter des candidats de
qualité
la plupart des entités d'aider des gens
comme nous des cabinets où naissent s2i
se disent ah les jeunes candidats
jeanvoine cv top terminé j'attends le
retour du client nous on fonctionne pas
comme ça ft 7digital item se concentre
sur son candidat accompagne son candidat
dans l'entreprise on est toujours en
fait pour nous on est toujours avec le
candidat le client est important mais le
candidat est très important pour notre
entité ftc digital item présentera une
nouvelle plateforme online entre
recruteurs et candidats
le 3 mars
maintenant que nous en savons un peu
plus sur la situation économique à saint
quentin en yvelines
nous allons aller rencontrer erwan le
gac conseiller communautaire délégué à
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle bonjour monsieur le gall
en dur alors il ya combien d'entreprises
ici présente alors il y à 21 une
entreprise de retenue deux ou trois de
maurepas et j'ai même appris une
entreprise voisine qui est de coignières
qui recherchent 40 ouvriers et
techniciens
vous voyez il
hier deux font tuer oui c'est axé sur
les jeunes on sait que c'est très
difficile pour eux la première embauche
et c'était vraiment l'idée booster
l'emploi ici oui alors évidemment c'est
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
ça s'est fait à maurepas pour des
raisons diverses que j'avais évoqué
dernièrement mais
le biais ses 18 30 ans accompagnés pour
entrer ici ses parts sur invitation donc
c'est soit les missions locales soient
des associations qui accompagnent le
pôle emploi voilà donc c'est une cible
précise une cible précise c'est pas non
plus par hasard
il représente 3% effectivement toujours
je vois donc il faut qu'on accélère ça
pour remédier en tout cas pour inverser
j'ai quand même permettre la corde du
chômage c'est une association qui est à
l'initiative de cet événement
je le sens qu'elle me tient à coeur
présenter l'amour un petit peu vous avez
eu président mais je suis retraité d'un
certain âge vous avez vu cette énergie
je trouve que ces belles valeurs pour
les jeunes de voir un monsieur retraité
avoir encore toute cette énergie de
données c'est du temps de donner pour
pour les jeunes et puis le concept est
intéressant donc c'est l'égalité des
changes donc c'est vraiment aussi sur
les territoires de la politique de la
ville ça c'est important sur les
quartiers difficiles
et la deuxième chose c'est que vous avez
qu'il y avait un bénévole de
l'association qui prend les inscriptions
et qui accompagne vers l'entreprise donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya une forme de
parrainage
mais il ya un suivi et ça c est ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne et je le vois
bien parce que la semaine de l'emploi
démarre ce midi j'étais avec le club
face et j'ai rencontré d'autres
notre interlocuteur et on voit que
parrain marraine ça fonctionne bien
n'allons pas chercher autre chose quand
ça fonctionne il faut activer ça et être
encore plus moteur sur territoire avec
ce genre de l'initiative et on le sait
il ya besoin d'une motivation c'est la
motivation qui permet d'avoir ces
posters et ils ont été préparés tous ces
jeunes janvier oui ils ont
moi je pense que c'est la clé vous avez
entendu d'ailleurs des chefs
d'entreprise leur prise de parole
lorsqu'il présenter leur entreprise
on sent bien que l'on puisse dire dans
les trois-quarts l'on dit motivation
motivation et on sent bien que même les
cv regardez il ya au moins huit dix
entreprises qui ont dit nous pas de
diplôme c'est pas grave
motivation oui c'est la clé ce sont des
jeunes qui sont des viennent de
quartiers défavorisés
c'est compliqué pour eux donc
on peut pas s'appuyer sur un diplôme on
peut pas s'appuyer sur une expérience
donc salle puis mental mais oui si l'on
est long voilà après faut les coachs et
c'est tout ça c'est le rôle aussi des
travailleurs sociaux des travailleurs de
structures comme les missions locales
qui doivent les accompagner les ça
marche
r je remercie mes serviettes bonne
journée réussie
mais ces jeunes motivés nous avons
décidé de suivre sabrina tout ali cette
jeune maman de 25 ans était terminée à
trouver un emploi
nous l'avons suivi durant sa préparation
cela fait deux ans que sabrina taouli
est à la recherche d'un emploi suite à
des problèmes de santé elle a dû
démissionner de son poste d'auxiliaire
de vie
je ne peux plus porter de charges
lourdes donc il faut que je me
reconvertisse dans un autre métier
malheureusement que quand je vois ma
situation aujourd'hui honnêtement mes
problèmes de santé je préfère les mettre
de côté trouver un emploi dans
l'immédiat pour pouvoir m'en sortir et
sortir aussi du cas du rsa de rendre des
comptes constamment à la caf et de
pouvoir trouver mon logement et être
avoir mon métier et enfin un travail
surtout est passé mon permis plus tard
par la suite on se voit finaliser les
démarches que vous allez entreprendre
demain que plus pour l'emploi pour
sortir la tête de l'eau sabrina se rend
tous les jours à la mission locale de
trappes
elle participe à des ateliers pour
améliorer son cv ou encore se préparer à
des entretiens
son but être prête pour l'événement coup
de pouce pour un emploi qui se déroule à
maurepas
je me prépare physiquement va dire je me
renseigne aussi sur internet
je me renseigne par rapport au métier
donc ce que je peux avancer ce que les
choses que je peux leur dire et en même
temps j'essaie aussi de comprendre le
métier donc aussi de leur expliquer ma
compréhension du de ce que ce qu' ils
s'attendent et de ce que moi même j'ai
compris quand je cherche quelque chose
on généralement ça paye
sauf que l'année dernière ça n'a pas pu
cette année sabrina compte postuler pour
un poste en boulangerie un emploi qui
lui permettra enfin ca l'obtient de
passer son permis de conduire mais l'on
retrouve sabrina qui est sûr l'événement
aujourd'hui
alors ça se passe comment ça se passe
très bien j'ai passé un entretien qui
s'est bien passé maintenant je vais
encore chercher un peu plus loin voir si
je trouve à une autre embauche aussi par
la suite
et c'est quoi la motivation hors de ses
côtes la gagne la motivation c'est la
gagne et surtout sortir du cadre du rsa
hawk est ravi de pouvoir rentrer dans la
société être réintégrés trouver un
travail
je te souhaite bonne chance ça va
marcher et nous on passe à l'agenda
échos
conférence le mardi 7 mars entre 12h et
14h le thème c'est l'entreprenariat
féminin
l'événement est organisé dans le cadre
de la semaine de l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin
ses co organisé avec réactive un réseau
de femmes dirigeantes ça se déroule au
ski cube à guyancourt
avant de se quitter un point sur la taxe
d'apprentissage y est à verser avant le
1er mars
cet axe permet aux entreprises de
participer au financement de
l'apprentissage et des formations
technologiques et professionnels le taux
de la taxe d'apprentissage et de 0.68 %
de la masse salariale
voici sa répartition 51% de ce qu'on
appelle la part régionale est destiné au
financement du développement de
l'apprentissage
il est aussi en quotas d'apprentissage
de 26 % destinés au financement des
centres de formation d'apprentis des
sections d'apprentissage et un hôpital
de 23%
destiné aux dépenses de formation par
apprentissage 7,8 échos c'est fini on se
retrouve le 9 mars merci nous avoir subi
et surtout bonne journée à tous
[Musique]